Ready for a story about superheroes
More TV superheroes just what the world needs be honest. Have you hung yourself yet?
Or what if I told you this was actually a story about super zeroes
losers
achingly pathetic metahuman goose eggs
How about it ready to feel better about your own miserable lives for the next hour or so?
Follow me
Our story begins as such stories do with a visit to a Nazi
I'm sorry cobbler
Mr. Morden, yes. Yes. You must be served on pure bun food or penis
Courage and your party knows who the village cobbler
Vaughn Fuchs was renowned for his theoretical
experimentation offering certain enhancements
for a price a
Price. Mr. Morden was more than willing to pay. Oh
I forgot. Mr. Morden, that's me
Well, it was me a third-rate bad guy a nameless entman a real
Nobody I
Forked over a king's ransom to that demented genius and if I knew what he had planned for me
I would have paid double. Can you hear me? Mr. Morden?
Yes
Are you ready? Mr. Morden?
Repeat after me please. The mine is
Again
Oh
Please touch me
Do you remember what it felt like to
Be normal
I'm working with some fascinating people each. One of them is just bursting with potential
I'm using
Every person I save is me fulfilling the pledge to my mom that she'll never get to hear
Father and I already discussed it trying to make her proud
knowing I'm the reason she's not around to see this is
Molten ever been mr. Morden sensor. Ah
Nobody
I've been my those freaks of yours for quite some time. Are we really the best people to hunt a supervillain?
Hell no you're all at my mercy
No matter how hard I hit where I had what I had I can't feel pain
You're as afraid as the rest of us
You're kidding me
This is what the world looks like when we try to live in it we don't have to get involved
Especially if we make things worse. I want to go home
We can do that. I don't even know what to hope for
I'm powerless. I have no clue how to fix this
Edith this mission you're on is your mission
I'm a criminal we bust
and the person we save
Is us chief said his enemies were coming for him don't
Be got this
What do you want from me
Oh
Don't you get it?
They are quite doomed
Everybody is Charlie. So we got to talk about Doom Patrol episode 1
This is the opening scene and they're just a little bit from the trailer giving you a sense for the rest of the series it
Is by a design meant to be the weirdest of DC Comics series because it's based on the Grant Morrison run if you've ever read
A Grant Morrison comic book, you know exactly what that means
So we'll do a new round of that DC streaming service giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave your favorite Doom Patrol
moment on the video
The opening scene totally sets the tone and works in a way that the Titans pilot episode just didn't quite come together
Because it's very serious material like it's a dark gritty series but none of the characters take themselves seriously in alan tudyk
Mr
Nobody character as the narrator sort of calls them on their bullshit in
Deadpool style breaks the fourth wall calling bullshit on all the writers all the producers for making a terrible series and calling out critics for
Prematurely hating the series before they seen it that was probably one of the funniest fourth wall breaks during the episode
lovely Rita
Queen of fifty cinema some critics called her the poor man's Deborah Kerr some critics called her the rich man's yevette Vickers
Critics, what do they know? They're gonna hate this show
I'm so happy that they got alan tudyk to be the villain for this as this omniscient narrator
I believe that he does this for all the episodes where he does the voiceovers
But he also like in this really weird way within episodes also refers to himself as the narrator
So just in general the series itself feels like it's put together
Much better than Titans was put together initially
And if you're wondering where Beast Boy is because this is a spin-off of the Titans series because you saw the same characters during Titans
Episode for Doom Patrol, but you met them in a slightly different way and they don't really address Beast Boy during the episode
So my guess is is that when they're doing all those montages and the time jumps as you're learning about robot man's backstory
That's when Beast Boy comes and goes but maybe later in the season
We'll see him guest star or pop up at some point because this is all happening during present day
Like it says 2019 when they're playing with the Train said so that's after the events of the Titans episode, which was during 2018
So very clearly they'll find some way to loop this in
I don't know how many Titans actors are actually gonna cross over to this
But I think the idea is is because cyborg is a classic Teen Titans character eventually cyborg will crossover with that series
But for now, it just seems like season 1 Doom Patrol. He's gonna be with this team of characters
The trailer footage has scenes from much later in the series
So you learn a little bit about cyborgs backstory across the first couple of episodes
And it's a little bit different from Justice League cyborg or the comic book version of the character
they haven't referenced anything about a mother box or a father box like Young Justice season 3 just
Did a version of cyborg we got the origin story?
It was a father box instead of a mother box that gave him his powers
but we haven't quite got to the point on Doom Patrol where they've completely
Explained that but really cool Easter Egg the person that's playing Silas stone
His father on Doom Patrol is actually Martian Manhunter from Smallville
So if you're a big Smallville fan, you'll recognize him immediately
Like hey, wait a minute
But he's not a huge character in the first couple of episodes
Cyborg is a bit of a slow burn but the cool thing about him though is that he also brings in a lot of Justice?
League Canon - he references a lot of Justice League things that are going on in present day during this Doom Patrol Titans universe
So you always kind of wonder what's going on with this version of Justice League because we know that Batman exists
We know that Wonder Woman exists and we know the Superman exists now because we have Superboy Conner Kent on Titans
But I don't think it's a spoiler to say that cyborg does
Reference a version of Barry Allen flash and it's not Grant Gustin and it's not as Remillard
So if you ever wondered if there's going to be a speedster on Titans eventually in a future season
I think they have a good chance that they do that because if you have a version of Barry Allen the flash
Within the universe then there's gonna be versions of other speedsters, too
like Bart Allen or even Wally West so this should explain why is
Separate from the CW DC TV universe and why they're probably not going to be involved with crisis on Infinite Earths this year
I know that's a big question because it's such a big comic book event. You feel like everybody should be involved with it
I think a lot of the things that Doom Patrol has going for it as a TV show though is that it's really well written
It's like legends of tomorrow in the DC TV universe
It's a bunch of characters that you might not necessarily care about as much as say the other bigger a list characters
But it just put together very well, and it doesn't treat itself, too
seriously
Like they're free to make fun of themselves the characters spend the entire
Episode taking shots at each other and watch now here comes hammerhead. This one's kind of an asshole. Except Jane's not here
You see little bitch
She's in a mood heard you the first time are you a raving douche? Hello hammerhead
Good to see you fuck off and die Rita crazy. Jane is probably one of my favorite characters from the series
I'm still kind of warming up to cyborg and some of the other characters like Rita Farr. Brendan Fraser is amazing
This is probably one of the greatest comeback stories ever for him
Especially the way they intro him in this series as the race car driver
So if you're not a big comic book reader for the most part all the stuff they're doing is from the Grant
Morrison Doom Patrol run so you can go read that if you want but they're being pretty authentic to those origins with a couple twists
Because obviously that was taking place a long time ago and this is taking place in 2019
But the other really cool behind the scenes Easter Egg
Is that the person that created this show Jeremy Carver also created Supernatural which is now entering its billionth season
But let me know in the comments what you guys think about all the characters or if you have any specific requests for bonus videos
I have no idea what happens later in the series
I've only seen the first couple of episodes and it does get a little bit better
The pilot is always a little bit raw
Compared to the rest of the season Titans is probably the best example of a show that gets better with each episode
Like you start out and you're like, oh, you know, I love Nightwing and I love some of these other Titans characters
But I just don't know how I feel about this series then going into season 2
It just sounds much more exciting because we have all this Connor can Superboy the team is coming together
We have Donna Troy Wonder Girl on the team and we have Deathstroke coming in with Grant Wilson
So it's just gonna be really cool to see what they do with that show
but while you wait for everything click here for my Titans season 2 teaser video and that
Post-credit scene with Superboy and click here to watch Ben Affleck explain why he quit being Batman before his contract was up. Thank you
Thank you so much for watching! Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight